how are you doing sir
i'm doing great steve i'm always very
envious of of your collection of toys
behind you
it just looks like just took wonderful
space
right i i'm a little envious of your
singing voice but you know there we go
um uh if you could get the financing for
any project tomorrow what would you make
and why
whoa what an unexpected uh question
um you know i would probably
do uh i would probably do a penguin
movie
right like i would that that that
continues to be
uh my my secret agenda uh
no i i don't know i don't know uh the
answer to that there's um
a script that i can't really talk about
right now that i'm very excited about
that hopefully
uh gets going sooner rather than later
that i that i would probably
uh use that money to finance i love
learning about the behind the scenes of
a making of a movie a show whatever it
is
what do you think might surprise people
to learn about the making of central
park
doing a fully animated series uh
from home for a year is pretty
surprising an astonishing feat
um people recording songs uh
through pillows in their closets uh is
probably not something people will think
about while watching season two at least
i hope that's not what they're thinking
about
uh and also the idea that so
many different artists work on this show
and
some incredible musical writers
especially season two we have big boy
shaggy
wyclef um just some tremendous talent
bobby and kristen um i i think people
are going to find themselves
uh if they love season one uh even
more immersed and in love with what
we've done season two
yeah season two is what we call good i
especially want to single out episodes
six
and eight uh episode eight is great
uh and i could get really specific but
enough of that um
uh how long does it take from when you
guys start writing
to when the show is actually able to be
aired
man you know we the whole process takes
about a year
i mean we we start with uh treatments
which become
outlines which then uh set up the
benchmarks for where we want the songs
to be
which then become scripts written with
music
which then become thematics which then
become animatics
which then become color which then have
to
find be finalized so it's it's a process
and it's a never ending process and and
there is uh this juggle that's been
going on the past few months where we're
literally still finalizing episodes of
season two
while to pre-visualizing um
season three and and juggling those
things is uh
kind of crazy um but also uh wonderfully
rewarding
uh that this is a show that continues to
uh pose unique challenges uh and i feel
like we continue to meet those
challenges
every step of the way and hopefully give
uh something that is as
entertaining as uh anything that can be
found out there and also hopeful
filled with that optimism um and that
joy
that i think you know a show like ted
lasso as well
um finds in itself at a time when the
world is filled with cynicism
um so that's what we strive to do i i
think you nailed that
um so season one had a sort of an
overarching story season two is a little
more free willing
freewheeling gets into more individual
stories
how are you what's season three going to
be like in terms of
are you doing like another like season
long story line or is it more
season two uh season three i would say
is a
pretty good hybrid i think we found our
sweet spot
um we are tackling some i i think that
there's a self-assuredness and ease
going into the third season of the show
that our incredible show runners
um kelvin u um and stephen davis
have just um allowed us to challenge
ourselves to tell stories that are
um complicated that are um
challenging and that are wonderfully
within the realm
of storytelling that we've done before
but also surprising and inventive
and doing things that we've never
tackled before
um i i got an email the other day from
leslie odom
jr just talking about a script that we
were writing in a song that we were
writing that
he just said he he brought him to tears
he was just so
blown away so i i think that we keep
raising the bar for ourselves and
hopefully
that bar will continue to get higher and
higher
i'm very excited that the show continues
to air on apple
the um uh the thing about the show is
that you guys have such incredible songs
in like every episode um how difficult
is it to make to
to deliver these great songs week in and
week out
it takes a lot of hair color because i i
keep going gray
from trying to uh rise to the challenge
of topping ourselves uh but the truth is
is that we never settle
um if if there's a song that comes in
and it feels
like it's sort of just kind of there
we'll scrap it we
we really keep uh wanting
and keep desiring and keep challenging
ourselves
to do songs that feel as timeless as the
stories that we're telling
and i think season two uh hits the mark
even more than season one in that
capacity definitely want to ask about a
few other things i'm almost
out of time uh what what's the status of
uh shrunk
uh the the the the status is
i fingers crossed think we're going to
hopefully be shooting it early next year
that that's
that's the the the status
right now now the status is ever
changing but
uh we're all feeling really confident
about it um okay my last thing for you
um i'm obviously incredibly excited
about the beauty and the beast
uh prequel series uh when and how you
co-executive producing co-writing you're
obviously very involved
when do you think that's going to be
filming and how many episodes are you
guys planning on doing
we're doing eight episodes uh it should
be
early next year we are in the midst
of um finishing the scripts right now
i can tell you that it is one of the
most ambitious projects i've ever been a
part of
um luke and i are so excited about
uh bringing these characters back to
life alongside a brilliant and
unique new talent in brianna middleton
uh playing this incredible new character
named tilly
and lisa tommy who's our director
is planning to do some unbelievably
ambitious things with this series
uh as well as um our our show runners
adam and eddie who are uh i i
really really really going places i
think audiences are not
necessarily ready for it i cannot be
more excited about this show
i think it's going to be enormously
special thank you for your time
good luck with the rest of the speed
dating you're the best brother great to
see you